made the mistake of going to the store
today not gonna do that again
because we're eight days away from
christmas and a lot of shoppers are just
scrambling to get everything on their
list the long line i was in was to mail
a package today oh no by the way i
looked my to-do list was over 200 items
long this was last week now it's like
143. some items may be harder to find
retailers are doing their best to get
your business christian costa rice has
some holiday ideas as the deadline
approaches
well brian and denise let me tell you if
you're like me you're probably getting
blasted by text reminders and probably
even emails about holiday sales every
day probably even every hour so we asked
are the deals better online or in person
i still need to shop more since i'm
traveling and bringing gifts as well so
i'll probably do some more shopping the
holiday race is on to find the perfect
gifts whether it's fashion home goods or
tech gadgets retailers at the las vegas
outlets pulling out all the stops to get
customers inside the stores after a
rocky season last year because of the
pandemic i like to see what i'm going to
get them and i like to have it with me
i don't want to wait for it to get here
still some people tell us online
shopping is more convenient because of
the delivery options i think online is
better and they have like
prime shipping and all that and
diversity as well i don't think you can
find everything in store so you have a
lot of options online this saturday also
known as super saturday is the last
weekend before christmas the national
retail federation predicting that day
more than 148 million consumers plan to
shop online and in store others say the
last minute rush is not for them i hate
the rush at the very end so
thanksgiving forward i'm usually already
done
so plan ahead i think that's the key all
right so as a last resort if you jump on
amazon for those last minute christmas
buys for prime products amazon prime
members can get those products on
christmas day if they order by december
23rd also target offering same-day
delivery via ship and jcpenney and
macy's doing two hour delivery on
certain items with doordash but remember
your orders need to be placed by the
24th so there you have it just a couple
more options there for you guys
to your door in two hours whatever you
need to do to get it there by christmas
that's it you had me at target yes
that's it i don't know i can go there
every day and i still find something new
you know who i bet was a is a really
cool mom
that lady with the glasses oh yeah i bet
she's just
definitely you know she goes i'm going
christmas shopping let me get my gear up
i got the whole thing i can see i can
see you doing it she's ready to roll
i've never met her but i like her yeah
we like her we like you actually her
husband and her entire family had those
classes
tell them we like them all into the
holiday spirit we like